i look completely different oh you just
wanted to point that out like
i know we like brushed over that but uh
yeah it's uh the friendship with joey
the anime man has ended i'm josh the
manga lad now
it's just the comments just like so
i got my ears pierced yeah that's one
big thing and then just yesterday i got
my hair cut yes so now i look completely
different yeah you look like the
the hacker character in the movie that
doesn't want to explain how hacking
works
so you know because i had like the every
time like i feel this is very much like
a youtube thing but like even if like
you slightly change how you look yeah or
you know slightly do something different
yeah it's like to some people it's like
what the [ __ ] it's like the end of the
world type of thing right yeah i think
it's just youtube comments work on
the first thing they think they can
comment about they comment yeah so it's
always the appearance because you see
that first yeah and it's like every time
i get like my hair cut or like i shave
or you know i guess in this case you
know drastically changed quite a bit my
favorite things is just like seeing the
reception to it regardless of if it's
positive or negative like you know to
all the people who said like hey joe you
look good
i appreciate that that's [ __ ] dope
thank you but my favorites are the ones
that of people just like
losing their minds in a negative sense
like like a family member yeah yeah yeah
it was the funniest response
the funny stuff so the one i saw on it's
always instagram that are the best ones
okay okay um
but like when i when i got the when i
posted the pictures of my getting my
ears pierced the top comment for a while
was
is he gay or european
and i was like yes i am a jojo fan thank
you
but then you know with the haircut for
instance like you know some people are
like hey you know i like your cut g you
know you always get those and then other
ones were like you know just like i
can't believe it he is like l plus ratio
he fell off
you fell off
yeah i saw one i saw one i saw a quote
retweet that was dead are saying like
you [ __ ] fell off and i was like well
definitely
yeah
yeah it's like what because i got a
haircut it was the same when i moved to
japan the same video i also dyed my hair
yeah yeah and even though i moved to
japan half the comments were just like
oh my god his hair
was like i just moved to japan
yeah like like your hair was like it's
like oh i have different hairs you know
responsible for different funnies now
you know it's like wow it's just i just
like the fact that you've had like
longer hair and like the same length
there now you have like shorter hair uh
to be fair this is the shortest i think
i've ever had it yeah and it's it's
weird does it feel good it feels good
the background feels good yeah but it's
like easy to how easy it is is it to
wash now oh that's the best part about
having a short hair it's it's it's
amazing i love it but like yeah i don't
know it's like so many people were like
why would you do that to yourself
like why would you do that it's like
like i [ __ ] stabbed a kid like it's
like it's like why would you why would
you do that now and i was like why not
so as someone who like rarely ever
changes their hairstyle how do you guys
pick what hairstyle that you like that
you like do or like how do you how do
you pick a new hairstyle i'm not
confident enough in my own abilities to
ever change my own style somebody else
has to do it for me right right then i'm
like
and then i stick with it yeah like to to
me every every time i have changed my
hairstyle in my life it's been someone
else recommending me a hairstyle to
change it to and i'm just like i don't
know if i like this i don't know if i
like this and it takes me like a good
old a good like gear or something it's
like build up my cars to be like okay
maybe maybe i'll go for this person's
advice and i change it and i'm like okay
well this is my new hairstyle now
how did you transition from sasuke here
to now
oh is that a suggestion yeah it was a
suggestion by my mates because they were
like mate uh you need to put stop
putting this much gel into your [ __ ]
hair
[ __ ] just comb it down and you're
like no no the sasuke hair makes me
everyone loves it everyone loves it it's
it's never going to change like this for
the rest of my life and i do it once i'm
like yeah this last hair is [ __ ]
stupid i don't know what's up i don't
know what i was thinking i've decided my
hairstyle based on what requires no gel
or wax i just hate putting [ __ ] in my
hair yeah i always hated that so i just
like whatever i can do when i roll out
of bed is the one i'm going for so
envious yeah i i i need i need yeah i
know he's not like perfectionist yeah
he's like
hand sculpting the perfect i mean but i
mean before today's episode like
majority of episodes is just my bed head
wait i don't do anything with it it's so
funny though people asking like what
shampoo and conditioner do you use i was
like uh head and shoulders
[ __ ] dove like it's nothing special
yeah i don't know it's like for me it's
like like i'm given like this you know
job right like
like youtubing and just like being on
social media where it's like
this isn't going to [ __ ] affect like
you know my videos right like it doesn't
affect my job yeah it's just a matter of
like personal preference so in my head
it's like why if i'm given this
opportunity where
i can kind of experiment with how i look
and then not really affect my job you
know maybe it might even affect it
positively for some people
why wouldn't i try it it's like you know
because like with my hair for instance
it's like if you hate this hair just
wait a month it'll go back to normal
it's going to go back to the length
you're comfortable with it's fine but
it's like you know why would i not give
it a good but also i feel like a lot of
that is just people not being used to a
look or new yeah of course because i i
remember like like i remember when i
first started growing out like a stubble
and everyone's like oh you're like weird
as [ __ ]
and even i did i thought man i look
[ __ ] weird i look [ __ ] weird as
[ __ ] with just a stubble because i've
never had a stubble or i've never like
grown out a stubble in my life even
though i've always known i could and i
remember like i was like working on
my latest vlog and i was looking at you
know i was looking at my uh
my trash taste video where i talk about
trash taste and then uh i was looking at
the previous vlog i did before i was
recording this one and it was the bbc
video that i did without a stubble and i
was like
man i look [ __ ] weird
like
like
now i think i look weird without a
stubble and i look back at all trash
taste episodes and i'm like man i look
really weird i don't know dude like when
you like go back to like episode one of
trash days and i'm in a [ __ ] ponytail
oh my god i completely i look at that
and i'm like you look homeless
i'm so glad
i don't look like this anymore but back
then everyone was like yeah the jesus
hair dude it looks [ __ ] sick and back
then i was like yeah
yeah you know what it kind of looks sick
not gonna lie
but now i'm just like no it like it it
really got to the point where like i
knew it was gross when like even aki's
mom who was like the most like [ __ ]
accepting like kind like never says a
bad thing about anything just one day
was like i think you should cut your
hair
i was like if you're saying that
maybe i should yeah i never want to hear
that i think maybe i should
not my own yeah i feel like though i
feel like i needed to hear that though
because like that's probably how dire i
looked
because like now now i know what she
means i look back and then i'm like yeah
you know what if i if i saw a guy like
that who i cared about i'd probably tell
him to cut his hair too yeah it's kind
of gross but it's like yeah i don't know
it's like
even with the piercings as well it's
like it was surprising how a lot of
people were like oh i thought your ears
were already pissed yeah and i was like
yeah now that you say i don't know why
i know it's never been that way but like
you had you had like that energy where
you had your ears pierced and yeah you
did you did yeah really because like
when you said you got your ears pierced
i was like didn't you already have your
ears pierced or am i just like dreaming
that up yeah everyone said that i was
like really it is weird how much like
just changing a little bit of your
facial features can change the
perception yeah when i was growing up my
beard a little bit i looked like [ __ ]
willem dafoe from the lighthouse
and i was like i kind of digged it
though but also at the same time it was
really [ __ ] annoying yeah yeah having
it long actually you actually reminded
me of linus tech tips more than anything
really yeah
i don't know why you just like we don't
want to wear sandals and socks side by
side
he is not drip you know
i think he looks good with the beard
i just like it wasn't william to face it
was like it was like linus tech tips
with a beard energy that i got from here
i don't know i i i take that one
now i think it's a reference
is that like the biggest change you've
ever done aside from like getting your
hair dyed and everything like that
i think i think you turning silver was
the biggest change right that was weird
yeah well i look at that level weird i
liked it when it was half blonde half
brown kind of yeah dirty blonde like
when the silver was fading right yeah i
like that i liked it towards the end
yeah i like that like segment but then
uh it's like i don't want to have to do
it again also she probably shouldn't be
dying my hair when i haven't got much
left to it so apparently that's a myth
is it really yeah it's not really yeah i
don't know uh my my hairdresser was
saying yesterday but she got stakes in
it
it's like it's her job people's hair
well no yeah but
that's true but also she was saying that
like unless you're like directly
applying the bleach onto the scalp which
yeah a hairdresser shouldn't be doing to
begin with it doesn't affect you i mean
i i don't know either way i i'm i'm yeah
i know why you're cautious about i've
got out of that phase as well where i
feel like i need to dye my hair i feel
like i'm just in the i'm in the boomer
stage now where i'm like it's it's
you're at this
stage it'll it'll do whatever it wants
and i will just deal with it
it does feel like regardless of age it
does feel like a stage that every
youtuber goes through yeah right it's
like oh it's the dyed it's it's either
they go through a bold stage or they dye
their hair
but it's it's the it's the i'm a
youtuber with a little bit of clouds
that is kind of like the youtuber
midlife crisis right oh people are
starting to look at me maybe i should
spice things up i never really wanted to
dye my hair it was like i think i was
what did you want to i was kind of
interested in it i was like i've never
tried it yeah i thought it could be
interesting and then when uh char who
dyes your hair right yeah she was just
kind of like yeah let's just do it and i
was like i was like
i mean i think i was in that phase i was
like yeah [ __ ] it everything in my life
is changing why not yeah so i tried it
and i remember i didn't like it
initially i thought
okay
and then it got to blonde and i thought
huh weirdly looks okay yeah i didn't
mind blonde yeah but then also
it didn't make me look a bit weird i
don't think the silver looked weird on
you to be honest i think out of out of
all the i think that compared to like a
red
or like a blue you know or like a you
know like a standard like i am a
youtuber youtube gamer color like yeah
yeah compared to that i think there's so
much
uh ninja
yeah yeah oh yeah ninja if you had like
me wrong if you had like if you had
ninja hair i would have been like oh
strong blue are you a twitch streamer
i mean i've done like what five or six
different colors now yeah i've done like
red blue green pink
purple and now i have this like gray
should complete the rainbow yeah i have
yeah
you just wake up day one day you're just
like i want to try something different
today which starburst color am i doing
today yeah exactly but that's a that's a
again that's an easy way to date my
videos right like if like i know exactly
what era this video is from just based
on what color my hair is yeah yeah so
it's kind of cool
but yeah i don't know it's like uh
like if you don't like this that's
totally fine uh you'll get used to it
within like a month you'll get used to
it with everyone yes yeah i'm not even
used to it right now i woke up this
morning i was like
like who the [ __ ] that i'm just
praying i'm like god please i hope i
don't have a weird shaped head when i
get bald exactly that was the one thing
i was worried about because
it really shapes out my face i don't
know how how do you how do you know what
your the shape of your head is you won't
know yeah you don't have to yeah until
you get to like this length and you're
like oh my head is [ __ ] weird i feel
like we should have found out a way to
figure out the shape of your head
without having to shave it all off
science come on we must have figured
something out right just like it scans
your head yeah i'm sure there's like a
[ __ ] filter or something
[ __ ] yeah the filters always look so
[ __ ]
it was like so cartoonishly bald
like like like like lex luthor wait no
ball person looks like this like yeah
it's like they just take [ __ ]
yeah yeah they all look like that and
it's like no
johnny sims doesn't even look like a
real ball person no he doesn't right
what a man what about the man the king
of balls